las encuestas recientes una hecha por
ejemplo por el washington post indica
que te oí ma cable el demócrata tiene un
49 por ciento de intención de voto
versus un 48 por ciento de klein john
king el republicano glenn young kim lo
que ha hecho es teniendo en cuenta que
el estado de virginia ha votado
normalmente y votan normalmente
demócrata pues entonces pues ha tratado
de acercarse al centro ha tratado de
alejarse al expresidente donald trump de
hecho no salió en ningún acto de campaña
con el ex presidente precisamente
tratando de buscar ese centro por su
parte pues te oí macauliffe el demócrata
ha hecho completamente propuesto ha
tratado de vincular a su contrincante
con el expresidente trump con los
mensajes radicales para ganar votación
para generar de alguna manera un miedo y
que los demócratas salgan a votar ahora
pero es un día lluvioso y eso puede
terminar afectando el resultado final